don't pull - a slicing its way across
the big screen a cutting down the
competition to assume the box-office
throne like any good blockbuster it only
got there by trimming its own fat to
become as tight and lean as it could be
finding the perfect balance of raunchy
chuckles slam bang action and emotional
payoff required a certain amount of
trial and error and now the Deadpool
creators have dropped hints about the
scenes that were cut from the film he
has a taste of what didn't make it into
the theatrical version of Deadpool -
warning spoilers ahead goodbye Hitler
director David Leitch told a squire that
originally a post-credits scene found
the time-traveling Deadpool in a nursery
where baby Adolf Hitler sleeps in his
crib there Paul rallies a strength and
decides to smother the future fiora
which apparently left teste screening
audiences feeling somewhat uneasy
ultimately the filmmakers realized it
wasn't a great way to send people out of
the theater criss cross cameo for
another post credits gag rights as Rhett
Reese and Paul Wernick conceived a bonus
round of rejected x-force auditions
according to Uproxx one scripted version
would have had Chris Evans reprise his
role as a Human Torch from 2005 s
Fantastic Four given that Evans has
always been game to play jokey cameos
there's a good chance he would have
accepted the opportunity however the
idea was dropped before any offers were
made in favor of the time-travel
shenanigans we got instead a Paul for
Paul though a loser
early on in the film there are a number
of scenes in which Vanessa appears and
speaks to Wade from the afterlife
however one dream sequence that have
been particularly difficult to shoot
ended up on the cutting room floor
Morena Baccarin told Good Morning
America that the scene took place in a
version of Vanessa and Wade's apartment
that was completely submerged in water
the filmmakers constructed an aquatic
set and put the actus reus koopa
training backer in who has a phobia of
being underwater had to be strapped to a
chair while submerged were you supposed
to be terrified
it didn't work try harder after the loss
of Vanessa
Wade's grief weighs on him so heavily
that he tries to do the one thing as
mutant healing abilities won't allow him
to do and his own life this was a
catalyst for a major bit of comedy that
ended up not making the final cut recent
Wernick revealed during a reddit AMA
that one stage there was a montage of
his increasingly absurd attempts to off
himself in which he tried everything
from drinking Drano to jumping into a
polar bear enclosure
despite the scrapping of the idea the
scenes were shot and are likely to
surface on the eventual blu-ray release
gamblin man back when they were working
on the first drafts of the sequel recent
Wernick told business insider they hope
to include a previously shot scene in
which Deadpool gives a rousing karaoke
performance of Kenny Rogers the gambler
while taking down a gang of bad guys
Wernick confessed to being so delighted
by reynolds performance that he kept the
video on his phone the writers had
originally hoped to include it in the
sequel but the gamble has yet to pay off
early drafts Reynolds has hinted that a
large foundational change was made to
Deadpool 2 during its development he
confirmed to Entertainment Weekly in
early drafts we had Deadpool as a dad
and by page I think two and a half we
realized that's a terrible idea
Reynolds also claimed that one quote a
sore spots about the making of Deadpool
2 was Fox's request to remove a joke
made at the expense of Disney he
wouldn't explain what the joke was but
it's hard not to wonder if the potential
fox's disney merger had something to do
with the cutting of the scene the
screenwriters told CBR that there was
another early draft with much more black
Tom Cassidy
he was intended to survive to the end of
the movie and play a part in the
climactic orphanage showdown the
reduction of his presence was mainly a
matter of budget but Reese consoled fans
by adding we can always go back in time
and make anybody alive so perhaps he'll
come back extended scenes director david
leitch was aware that he couldn't just
lean on senseless violence for the
sequel and he tried to be mindful of how
much was too much he told Bloody
Disgusting that the opening montage in
which Wade mows down a bath house full
of Yakuza was much more intense before a
left the cutting room
he described quote a seamless 360 shot
but he was particularly sorry to lose
another scene that only partly made it
into the film include
- delightfully surprising cameos hidden
in plain sight behind prosthetics and
thick fake accents our Matt Damon and
Alan Tudyk as two country boys debating
the merits of proper bathroom hygiene
Josh Brolin revealed in a Collider
interview that this scene was quote cut
in half with cameos like these it's safe
to assume the rest of the scene will
turn up eventually thanks for watching
click the loupe icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your lefty
[Music]